i want to start by saying congrats on
the
movie
fantastic sequel thank you thank you
right what's funny is you guys literally
finished the movie like yesterday
it sort of feels that way yeah so it's
sort of like i think today you're
legitimately hearing the first reactions
no for sure i mean i think that
it was finished so such a short time ago
um the turnaround was always very quick
on this film and john's attention to
detail is going to be
you know challenged because he's he's
under a time crunch
but i ultimately have always just
thought this
was a knockout and i think it's
incredible i'm so proud of it and proud
of him
but hearing the reactions from everyone
has been the best like it's been the
best because i think there's a theory
you know if a first movie is beloved
that with the second film you're gonna
be like
chum you know people are gonna go for
you
and they're to smell some blood in the
water that they want to sort of act on
but actually people have been so
generous and so enthusiastic that
it's just awesome it's awesome um i
normally don't do this
but uh the movie ends yeah and it's one
of those
few times where i'm like oh [ __ ] i want
more yeah like
right at the beginning i'm like this is
not cool so i brought up with john has
he already started thinking about part
three and he basically said yeah
yeah you know like yes he has a whole
arc of ideas that could
work um i think he just wanted to see
how people responded to this one before
he fully engaged his brain on the third
one but
he he has he has a couple of great ideas
on it
well he he said something to the effect
of because i asked him about the title
was it always part two
and he said it was you that came up with
like part two of a trilogy or something
yeah so is it designed as a trilogy
why not i mean i just i i always said
when we were approaching this one i said
i think you need to think of it not as a
sequel but this is chapter two
this is just a continuation i think
there was such an investment in this
family
such mileage for expansion on this kind
of extraordinary world
that this is the continuation as this
family have to venture out the story
ventures out the world gets bigger but
i think i always felt he was still going
to write something
muscular and intimate and intense you
know
i think this room a hundred percent
right um
uh what how is it what was the first
thing you shot on day one
and do you still get like nervous yeah
yeah
because you've done the role before so
you're you know what i mean well i'm
bricking it
for the whole first week on every movie
i do i think
the anticipation gets the better of you
but it was easier with this
character because i know her so well
she's deeply personal to me the
relationships are established
i have a lot with noah who's just divine
and
my first scene was um when i come out of
the furnace
and he's trying to stop me from going to
the pharmacy
so we had that scene a lot of sign
language and all that stuff
and then um and there was i think we did
the bear trap run
next which was one of the hardest weeks
of shooting i've ever experienced it was
like a hundred degrees
it was in a co we shot it in a coal mine
an abandoned coal mine
and so the dust people were covered soot
black up their noses in their ears like
it was just
that was um that i think that was the
hardest week for me
what's great about that and i gotta go
is that i've been on sets where it's
like that
and everyone on the crew is wearing the
mask but you can't because you're the
actor
and and so like you i mean it's weird
because it's
kind of weird like everyone's in
balaclavas and stuff and you're just
exposed to the elements with no shoes on